[Music]
money money absolutely I think back when
in the ' 80s or '90s back then um like
that's when lawyers law firms were
actually paying attention to family
court system before then they didn't
really it it wasn't really um common for
law firms to have a family court section
where they family law yeah because it
wasn't lucrative back then but now it's
such big business that every single law
fir has a you know but not every single
one but mainly now it's the norm to have
a family law section and because
obviously the house the house is the
biggest asset and so if you get that
sold big money guaranteed
guaranteed and that's why the men never
the how yeah